er will in new york oder nein nicht so
viel
bist du eure hey was geht ab und jetzt
willkommen warum hast du etwas glaubt
und willkommen beim ein video ja leute
ich weiß ich habe meine haare richten
wir sind jetzt wieder kurz also ja die
sind schon kurz also die sind schon
ziemlich cool also ich finde die recht
schon fast zu kurz
naja warum sollte eigentlich nicht gehen
mehr wie man leider schon gesehen hat
wie ihr wahrscheinlich alles schon
gesehen habt habe ich heute wieder
glücklicherweise nicht dabei ist hier
noch was trinken wir waren eben beides
schaffen beziehungsweise ich habe den
schatten und habe ein paar produkte
gekauft und der alex muss jetzt raten
nur für die gut sind und wie man sie
verwendet wo das war richtig gut
damit habt ihr schon gehört ich habe sie
zudem geschickt wurde sie hatten ein
bisschen rum euro kostet also gibt und
ich bin auch gespannt weil mit so ein
paar hygieneprodukten kann ich natürlich
immer viel anfangen
in unserem bad steht doch nicht so viel
deswegen ich würde sagen wie lange
schlange wenn ich das noch mal machen
soll dass man doch nach oben da und
müssen das jetzt ich hätte hier ist ja
voll wenig ist ja voll kleiner und ja
also dann würde ich sagen wir fangen mit
dem ersten produkt setzt das ist mit der
verpackung also wir haben hier ein
evelin apple in new york
[Musik]
kennen sie auch immer also wissen jetzt
denn die mädels alle was das ist kann
man das sofort jetzt sehen wir dass die
recht kleine ich weiß nicht ob das alle
wissen aber paar wissens auf jeden fall
hier zum nasen haben wenn man was
zwischen den zehen hat kann das backup
oder man könnte theoretisch auch damit
die augenbrauen so käme das ist also das
hier ist etwas wichtiges das kann ich
doch irgendwas ist da doch ich bin die
nase hallo
ja ich habe keine ahnung also eher über
den new york sagt mir was aber mehr war
es ja ohnehin noch okay gibt immer deine
finger damit kannst du einmal hier die
haut so wegschieben
so unterschiedlich gründer 7 das sieht
jetzt von ungesunden ein ja und jetzt
weiter und und den dreck wegmachen unter
den fingern
das ist vielen direkt unter also kannst
du auch machen aber ich suche tochter so
was gar nicht so eine stelle was ist
nicht immer so wenn du jetzt hier
sowieso keine hautfetzen hast kannst du
dir so hiermit abreißen und so eine
scheiße kauft ehrlich jemand ja also das
ist mit abstand das unnötigste produkt
von dem ich je gehört habe und jetzt
einfach mal auf das benutzen seite hast
du auch irgendwie produkte die noch
kleiner waren weil ich meinen die passen
ja kommen aus bild ja leute die haben
wird
das ist jetzt aber für die nerven
warum irgendwie
für die nachzügler ich meine sogar zum
das könnte aber auch wie die augenbrauen
sein um die orders mode ist nicht alles
für die nachrücker für die augenbrauen
zu machen nach 1
vielleicht irgendwie unbequeme oft
strahlen oder so ja genau um die wimpern
so ein bisschen hoch zu machen und so
dass inzwischen die kenne das ist für
zwischen den zehen jahr und die zeit
sich noch einsamer zu machen letztere
kommt natürlich jeder sofort drauf mit
so einem ding reinigt man die zähne das
wussten wir nur an i
das wussten mindestens 70 prozent wenn
ihr so ein teil zu hause habt dann
schreib das auf jeden fall mal in die
kommentare weil ja
[Musik]
alter kurses findet julia erklärt mal
guckt mal genau hier ein wo ist das team
richtig erzogen
ich glaube das kenne ich schon das ist
um hier
wenn man mal wieder ein paar haare zu
schneiden kann man das so ist dafür ja
aber das brauche ich so toll ist jetzt
sogar 33 vietoris 1 keine ahnung
manchmal kurz und bei dir die augen vor
wie so ein bisschen wie wir das fällt
mir wenn ich nicht ganz so hast du mal
kurz von den haaren hier ein bisschen
was mitnehmen bei dir ist schon klar
dass das wirklich funktioniert ne na.de
ganz online
ganz ohne belohnung zentimetern nicht so
viel
bist du eure das geht auch gar nicht
nötig ich bin bereit wir machen weiter
mit dem nächsten produkten zwar ist dass
[Musik]
es in eschenburg 30 läden ich weiß aber
ich nicht also mascara das wort sagen
was aber für meine firma andreas krieg
hat oder ich höre man das jetzt benutzt
weiß ich auch nicht wollte mal kurz
etwas ist aber für die wimpern
also man kann es für die eltern benutzen
weiß von keiner für die unzähligen
filmen steckt man sich in die nase für
die augenbrauen
was ist da dran flugzeug hey das ist ok
anders als ich benutze das immer
meine augenbrauen hoch zu bürsten wir
hatten jetzt nicht gemacht also gut ja
wirklich ein tolles produkt da kann ich
jedem empfehlen falls ihr euch das
kaufen wollt auf jeden fall über meinen
amazon affiliate link von links einfach
mal ganz oben im video beschreibung wir
den griechen geld bisschen geld ja wie
viele sagt gibt es noch 22 da war es
aber nicht so kreativ oder wir machen
heute mit dem nächsten produkt eine
bürste ohne bürsten also wenn wir das
jetzt einer von weiten zeigen würde
würde ich sofort sagen dass eine bürste
a-ha zum zum barthaare weg machen
euro jetzt gerade verklungen sind also
nicht klingen aber so nicht auf hallo
ich also das teil hat er zwei
verschiedene seiten einmal hier die
klingen und einmal die a8 obwohl woche
erinnern
das macht alles kaputt hallo herr kuba
wird mein name ist jetzt gerade so aus
jetzt mache ich einmal so richtig kann
und jetzt sieht er so aus
ja dann ist das entweder für die
fingernägel oder für die fußnägel ich
denke mal für die füße aber ich weiß
nicht genau das ist so eine hornhaut
rubel also jetzt also ist das jetzt für
den fußnagel oder für die hornhaut
anstellen sagt das habe ich gar nicht so
was machst du hast du gar nicht
das ganze ist ja oder nein sagte sofort
stoppen hat doch was auch das internet
wirklich
ja auf jeden fall ein ganz tolles
produkt kann ich auch jedem nur
empfehlen wenn ihr zu viel waren haut
habt wurf macht dann hunderte einfach
mal den war lea made in germany wie sein
register bürste ohne bürsten so dann
kommt es zum letzten produkt ich hoffe
jetzt das letzte ist das beste also ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen was mir jetzt
fünf produkte schon gezeigt und ich kann
mit noch keinem im geringsten sinne
etwas anfangen ein bisschen enttäuscht
ja ich habe dir selbst nicht also ich
besitze er selbst keins von denen außer
dass ihr okay das letzte produkt wie
genau man es anwendet habe ich sie also
weiß es selbst noch nicht so genau
ich kenne das aber also ihr müsst jetzt
hat sich das verschmieren
das heißt wenn ich jetzt irgendwas dazu
sagen weißt du kannst du gar nicht sagen
ob das jetzt richtig ist oder nicht
aber genau das ist richtig der sinn vom
video
ich weiß wie man das auf macht aber ich
weiß nicht wo man sich das gar nicht
mehr los das ist das aber davon ist er
ja okay leute wir machen jetzt mal ein
ziel von aus natürlich nicht dass eine
creme einfach für die fürs fürs gesicht
oder das sieht aus wie alter oder leute
guckt euch das mal an bord hatte hörte
ich zeige euch mal noch aber ich bin
echt voll wie sonst auch machen nicht so
heute warte hier kommt das keine geruchs
funktion gibt hier noch ein
das haben die beiden bands meine nase
leute hier so sieht das nämlich auf ja
und was soll ich jetzt eigentlich sind
deiner hand vielleicht ist das was für
die haare
ja ja das ist also ich würde schon sagen
dass der hof die sich lieber ich würde
schon sagen dass er auf jeden fall die
creme für irgendwas weil das kann man
auf jeden fall cool das fühlt sich an
wie wie sternenstaub windows im blick
ist ernst mach dir weil du hast das so
sehen das gesicht ist alles viel weicher
nicht aber es muss man es abwäscht
abwaschen ja leute also ihr könnt ihr
jetzt mal in die kommentare schreiben
was ist in so kapseln sieht aus wie
alter und machen weiter und alles oder
ist es darum wurden ja heute das war auf
jeden fall kommt das kannst du doch war
ja heute ja das war die dm produkte
erraten stunde mit alex ich hoffe es hat
euch gefallen marie ja ok aber ich muss
dir erwarten
ja ja genau mit alex von marie ich hoffe
es hat euch gefallen das war doch nach
oben da wenn ihr das nochmal sehen
wollte und ihr könnt ja meine kommentare
schreiben was marie bei dm kaufen soll
ansonsten schaut nochmal ins tor vorbei
bei uns beiden und wir sehen uns dann
übermorgen wieder da kommt mega cooles
video
ich wünsche euch eine schöne woche
willst du noch sagen zum schluss alles
klar besser so